and i know of an sra survivor for
example who was
abused since a very young age since she
was practically
a baby and she has
hundreds of altars literally hundreds
um it's not impossible for them to
integrate
all their alters into the core
personality
but it usually takes years of therapy
to do that it is a survival mechanism
because the alternative if they couldn't
split into their different personalities
would have been simply losing their mind
having a complete mental breakdown so
in order to survive they have this and
and it's interesting to note some
some sra survivors get so used to it
and see the positive side of it that
they find it hard sometimes to let go
of the separate alters and integrate
them into their core personality because
they've grown
rather fond of having that alter
or too used to it perhaps okay
um so one way
i think to find out more about sra in a
particular location or
or city is to talk to the
therapists who specialize in dealing
with
did and
see if they are willing to share with
you what they know
some of them may be afraid to talk about
sra because they think that it will
damage their careers if they do so but
others will be
more willing to just be upfront about it
because they believe in exposing this
evil
in fact the only way to stop this evil
is to expose it
and for too many years it's been hidden
from public knowledge
so i was in this building full of
sra survivors who were shifting from one
altar to another
they were badly damaged
i felt so sorry for them it can be a
shock to anyone who's not seen this
before
um and the doctor told me that the local
member of parliament had visited him on
another occasion recently
and that she did not last more than
about one and a half hours before she
made some excuse to leave
because it was just too disturbing for
her to see
um but yeah in that sense i was thrown
in a deep end and i stayed there the
whole day
uh finding out what i could and
hearing the stories very sad stories
of some of the survivors now some of the
things you hear about
satanism compared to what you're talking
about
i know there's people in the uk
that run these quote satanic temples
and they will openly discuss
how satanism is about the worship of
oneself
or the introspective
behavior of facing your own problems or
facing your own demons looking
inward um and it's sort of a love affair
with yourself so how does
how do these people differ from
these sort of satanic covens that you've
investigated
well i think uh in essence they don't
really differ from them very much
but they are presenting
a very small aspect of what they really
believe
uh for example
i do surveillance on satanist covens
and i know that they like to meet not
only on the dates of the satanic
calendar
uh they also like to meet on the birth
dates
of their members because as you said
earlier what the satan
satan is temple claims
that they also believe in the worship of
oneself
so for them the birthday is like the
birth of
god because they regard themselves as
being gods and
satanism is not only about worshiping
the devil as
god but considering oneself as god
and so the birthdays of their members
is uh a date for them to have a ritual
and a significant
um religious day you could say
and and so they haven't told the full
story
which is that they're worshiping
themselves as gods
does not negate
they're worshiping the devil as god
they're doing both
they're doing both but they know people
have
generally a bad impression very rightly
so in my view
of the devil so they keep the devil in
the background you say oh well we're
just worshiping ourselves
what's wrong with that well the problem
is that
also leads to an attitude of
we can do whatever we want and
there's no such thing as us doing wrong
uh we can do whatever we want satisfy
our desires
regardless of who it may harm as long as
we get our satisfaction
because we are gods we can do anything
god can do anything
i can do anything and you've heard the
phrase probably of
do what thou wilt do whatever you want
and anton lavey as you know the former
uh head of the church of satan in the
usa
he summed it up uh as do whatever
the wilt is the
all the law that satanists will have
is to do whatever you want
and that of course includes doing
whatever you want even if it's at the
expense of others
even if it causes harm to others doesn't
matter as long as you satisfy your ones
and after all uh
god can do whatever he wants so i am a
so-called god
i can do whatever i want uh and all that
matters is that i have
my needs fulfilled no matter how
perverse those needs may be
alistair crowley the leading satanist in
the uk
said the same thing and in fact i'm
pretty sure that what alistair crowley
said
influence anton lavey to say something
very similar
and so this is the danger of
this attitude of a person being god
it's not only that they can do whatever
they want
they can do the most terrible things to
others
and justify it
not in an objective way of course it's
purely subjective but justified
to themselves on the belief that
i'm all-powerful i am god i will decide
what's right and wrong
because god decides what's right and
wrong and what's right
is whatever satisfies my needs so you
imagine you
that belief in in the hands of someone
who believes that it's okay
for adults to sexually abuse children
well as long as i get my needs satisfied
no matter
how many children i abuse
do what they will i will do it
i am a god and i will
have my way so this is the problem with
uh this kind of presentation they're
trying to make
satanism seem harmless and respectable
even
but they're not giving you the full
picture in practice the full picture
is you get practices like sra which of
course they will
more often than not in fact i've never
heard of them
actually acknowledging its existence
deny
that it exists because sra is a very
inconvenient
reality that stops them from being
mainstreamed especially in the usa i
believe
satanists are trying hard to get
mainstream recognition
uh as as a supposedly respectable
religion
uh whereas in the uk it's more hidden
but there are
some moves towards more recognition for
example
in the royal navy in the uk in 2004 they
had recognition
to have satanist rituals done on royal
navy ships
so so you're saying on the outside
on the outside basically for face value
and in terms of what they portray to the
media
is like i mentioned before it's
an introspective look at worshipping
oneself
you know there's they don't portray that
we can do whatever we want and obviously
the child abuse stuff they don't want
that to be
in the public light that's sort of once
you get behind the veil
they reveal that to you it sort of
reminds me of scientology
for are you familiar with scientology
yes um
but just to add what you mentioned about
behind the veil i have
uh i know some british ex-satanists
who have since left satanism
and they have blown the whistle on what
goes on
in satanism so some of the things i've
said
just now uh is backed up by those
statements by ex-satanists uh that
as you rightly said a lot of it is
behind the veil and they don't
undervalue pulled
they want to be able to stay there
so